kaisa je te lâcherai jamais l'adorent a
vraiment la base et les chauffeurs libre
et c'est là où le sachet et c'est un
pote à la radio et raymond nous il a
décidé lui aussi né comme benali et a
décidé de se mettre entre parenthèses
dans l'émission pendant quoi de trois
mois deux mois
en fait le gars c'est le seul gars qui
était pas dans l'émission mais c'est le
mec qui twittait le plus ce sont les
missions méga ne veut pas de ce plateau
mais vous le souhaitez en guide qui fait
je suis là quand il avait besoin de se
ressourcer de se ressourcer et de
retrouver la vie normale
je crois que là je ne rigole pas saddam
et c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que
j'entends les précieux c'est vrai nom
mais il était il à lui j'ai mal vécu moi
le deuxième confinement je vous jure que
c'est vrai mais joue aujourd'hui c'est
pas une bonne et bien malgré eux gagnent
pas on est sérieux
pas parce que moi en fait j'ai un
problème c'est que moi je ne dis rien
mal je m'en bas tellement il ya ceux de
bali un compliment bientôt plus à la
maison genre la foudre tombe à défaut
sortie a mal vécu ce courant parce que
sa tenue c'est quelqu'un que tu à fleur
de peau non mais c'est vrai il est à
fleur de peau lui c'est comme envoyer un
abricot quand vous touchez un abricot à
peu de pêche
il peut être tout doux et parfois il
peut être un peu rêche lui accroche et
lui exactement la croche et lui il était
comme un abricot sec c'est-à-dire un
abricot morts
oui c'est vrai tout est pourri on lui
avait refusé
exactement
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé là-bas
c'était ça c'était que le deuxième
confinement le premier confinant je m'en
foutais tout le monde était confiné donc
j'ai dix essais on n'a pas le choix
le deuxième confinement et nous ont
confiné les gens de la restauration et
c'était super dur à vivre
et j'avais prédit j'avais pu la force de
venir j'avais plus envie de venir je
suis dit c'est dit j'ai chaud le con
j'ai besoin de souffler ça va pas je
suis pas bien alors tu as raison c'est
vrai que je tweetais plus devant ma télé
de changer tél
et comme tu es tu es encore un petit peu
dépressif qu'il faut dire qu'après qu'il
faut dire aux gens c'est pas parce qu'on
n'est pas là que tu nous as et bien non
on a droit aussi nous de dire bien sûr
on a en actions menées en fait mais et
voient au contraire il a vraiment depuis
qu'il a regardé depuis deux jours on se
régale mais on parle bien je me régale
être aussi de rigueur
il a faim exactement manga famille la
femme à ce que je veux c'est des gens
c'est pour ça que vous allez faire le
ramadan tout le temps où les femmes et
où tu as raison tu sais que tu disais
toujours faut venir ici pour s'amuser
bien sûr et pas à vous amuser venez pas
rester chez vous venez pas ici est juste
pour prendre l'argent au caucase je
venais pour être vous même et pour rire
et moi je venais pas dire énervé deux
des principaux c'est vrai non moi je
venais pour m'énerver avec tout le monde
c'est pas la peine non la latte et là on
voit la nasa sans rigoler frère on
dirait qu on dirait la meuf
tu sais d'entre eux connaissent bien
sont effrités heureux à feu par garde
s'est créé sur ton groupe malheureux
c'est pas mal ça qu'on fait ça je sais
pas tu es sympa assez sa passe est très
réel